oh well this is what i'm forgetting if
my cleaning lady sees a a
a fancy maid costume she might think i'm
cheating on her with another maid she'll
be like am i not doing my job she like
that's
it's almost like i have it all written
here
this is the most challenging thing about
comedy is that you're trying to do a
joke but every region of the country
calls something different it's like sip
up juice box
right it's the same shit bounce house
bouncy castle or bouncy house i say
bounce house would you say moon bounce
we said moonbounds
but
i know we're in new jersey so your
princesses get a castle
yeah okay we're not i'm not going to do
anything
in san diego what do you say new jersey
i mean sorry what do you say about it
what do you call bounds house
a bounce house
but
you're not you're not saying that with
confidence if i say 23 and me instead of
ancestry chess saying ancestry tests is
like silly
it's obvious that you're trying to not
say
23andme you know what i mean that's not
how people talk do you have any jokes
about paperwork
i have no jokes about paperweights um
uh seinfeld has some great ones i have
jokes about the emotional weight of
writing jokes
all right so the thing is this
this set has evolved over the past year
and the order has changed so many times
bottle of pills represents a different
iteration of this set
and
i actually do need to take that how how
am i going to do this show without my
burberry 500.
i mean what could go wrong damn it
i mean i know this i know all this
okay
is it funny um
i mean i also could do like for the
proposal
um and then i would go into my romantic
speech
will you make me the happiest woman in
the world oh and let me buy my own
engagement because you can't afford the
one that would make my friends
on instagram jealous you can't afford a
ring that would make people jealous on
tick tock
oh why do i do this for a living
ah
give it up for my good friend and yours
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a documentary i need you to
watch immediately why are you
complaining about this miracle in your
living room i'll turn this song off in
three minutes
daddy daddy daddy daddy and i deserve to
see this v-neck and this dick that is
the move that's illegal in the nfl i
would like a big beaver magazine please
i made 74 nickels for this bullshit shit
we put it on our face
we can plie down to the spelling bee i'm
on the moon it's like two crocodile eyes
coming out of the pond
should we just get in the van with that
guy
[Music]
i feel like that was good can i have my
ring please
she doesn't get it
[Music]
i know can you believe i'm not married